hi everyone it's Jerry I have a nice
attacking game to share with you from
the 2012 Chinese Chess Championship on
the white end dingler Inn and he's
playing against Luc
we have on board a Queen's Gambit
declined three nights
D takes C4 signals the Vienna variation
white now has a central majority two to
one
and it is set into motion
right away and in the most aggressive
way
with E4
with E4 white is willing to play this
position as a Gambit that's what we
observe in this game
if white wants to play this position
balanced material the pawn would go one
step and white regains the pawn without
a struggle
okay in this game it's E4
Bishop B4 pinning the Knight Bishop
takes C
Knight takes e
castles Knight takes Knight Pawn takes
Knight let's pause for a moment black
has just won a pawn
and I'd like to throw under the
microscope the one piece exchange that
just occurred there it was not just
night for night
it was Black's King Knight
for White's queen that I think we do
well to add these identifiers to certain
pieces
why am I drawing attention to this well
without the king Knight
without Black's King Knight
the king side could be that much more
vulnerable
a king Knight on F6 is a great defender
look at the squares it controls G4 H5
might the queen now be thinking about
being deployed to the king side
making use of those squares it watches
over from F6 the H7 Square might there
be sacrifices on H7
it can be a sorely missed piece not
having the king Knight when the king
Knight is traded for the queen Knight
additionally if we look at some
um the Tempe in the position or the
Tempe of the remaining Knights
the king Knight is just a blink away
from entering
White's kingside and being a pest one
way or the other
and it's going to require the White
Queen Knight to take to Tempe before it
could maybe fulfill the role of the king
Knight getting to F6 time
is a very important factor
in positions like this with Gambit play
so a couple things to keep in mind there
now at this point black should feel full
not go ahead and eat another Pawn on C3
the best move is the move played in the
game Bishop to E7 well really one of
these two withdrawing the bishop
watching over Knight G5 or maybe
Knight to E5
Bishop E7 was played in this game
however I want to draw some attention to
this line here
suppose black is picking up this second
Pawn
my initial impression of this position
was oh the idea is to now get on this
diagonal since it's been abandoned after
Bishop takes on C3
be willing in other words to give up
even more material
and try to do something along these
beautiful diagonals one day
not the best way to go because black
could say I've had enough I'm not going
to take any more material I'm going to
play A5 look to cut out the bishop and
finally
I look forward to castling
okay the best continuation would be to
play Rook B1
if black is winning the second Pawn
the best continuation C5
but let's see what would happen after
castles black is already losing
and here's a here's a line or two that
you may find appealing Rook B3 while
black has won that second Pawn white is
now winning an extremely
valuable Tempo against the bishop
and soon
this Rook is going to act like a tank in
the attack against the black king side
pivoting on G3 or H3
suppose this Knight tries to come to the
rescue too late there's a sacrifice on
H7
and it's already a mate in three
F6 you take here Etc
some other line suppose black tries to
scare the Knight
it's not easily scared
Rook G3
the white could afford to give up
material
if it's not captured you could move the
Knight Maybe
capture on H6 let's see what happens
after the capture here a queen move
Bishop F6 is crushing F6 this is still
crushing
D5 that's as far as I'm going this
position is getting broken down
winning for white
I want to give you an idea of how you
can be proceeding against a player who's
greedy taking on C3 anyhow
move played in the game Bishop to E7 we
can't make use of G5
so we go to E5 Paving the way for
the queen to enter the scene there's not
a king Knight around
watching over that square there's now a
pin
against the G Pawn
this is where black
uh goes wrong
move 10 he goes with C5 it seems natural
enough challenging the center opening up
the queen maybe to put pressure on the
Knight opening lines
um
but it's a little bit too slow
considered best is Knight to C6 this is
something I found
instructive in preparing for this video
uh what is the idea what's Knight C6
I thought to myself why why are you
giving white the opportunity to maybe
damage the structure like this
isn't the idea to play Knight takes
Knight the idea is not really to play
Knight takes Knight
because that would invite uh a pawn into
the mix and having control over F6 would
mean that the bishop isn't able
to sit on the F6 Square from that point
it's an important defender of G7
so what is the point behind Knight to C6
here it is
just to fill you in
it is to next play Knight E7 and
transfer itself to either G6 or F5
interfering with the coordination on G7
maybe just looking to kick the bishop
away
a key defensive resource that black has
here
this is a position
that
Carlson had as white against kramnik
kramnik went with this move and was
successful
um with it and by successful I mean he
went on to win not just draw
so it's a very strong
uh defensive resource not caring about
doubled double double isolated Queen
side pawns that's one less attacking
piece black would have to worry about
in any event Knight C6 was not played
in this game it's C5
and it's you may already consider this a
winning attack at this point 11 Moves In
not much choice
Bishop F6 to defend G7
Bishop D3
there's no fear of winning the bishop
this guy has an important role defending
G7 so
it's no longer there
that's going to lead to me
so what do we do
Rook to E8 that's the move played in the
game white does have a threat if you try
capture on D4 Knight C6 Knight D7 all of
those moves are met with Queen E4
forming a battery
how do you stop the queen from getting
to H7 you'd have to play G6 and then
your Rook would fall so
we see the point now behind Rook to E8
Paving the way for G6 without dropping
the exchange
now comes F4 so nearby
before even F4 is played
white is already close to just
destroying the king side
just starting to sacrifice pieces
so for example
there are already moves like Bishop
takes H7 not winning but it's close
capturing there capturing here
giving a check
taking here with check white has at
minimum a perpetual and is so close to
having a third piece enter the attack
but it's a little too slow
in these variations white wants to be
able to make a rook move
to the third rank right now but doesn't
have that option
so with F4 white is now in a position to
go with the Rook lift this is not just
about defending a knight or supporting a
piece on G5
that actually shows up later on in the
game some Bishop G5 move F4 is about
getting this Rook into the attack
there's already four pieces and a fifth
is right around the corner
okay from here it's G6
white is able to now smash through on
the king side
Bishop takes G6
F takes G6 notice white is taking first
with the bishop
so that when the Knight takes this is
going to be the more aggressive
remaining piece in the position tough to
ignore it tough to not capture it here
we have discoveries the night jumping
back to E5 if it's declined
for example King F7 there are these
moves where you could look to coordinate
on F7 this is a crushing attack for
white
if black is declining the knight in this
position
okay in the game
black goes ahead and wins the night so
why does sacrifice two minor pieces
and only gotten two pawns but where is
the King's shelter
a winning attack is what we have here
all Spectators on the queen side
from here Bishop G5 this is a very nice
move
eliminating a key Defender for the king
side
and nearby we have this
what do you do about that
in the game it's Bishop takes Bishop
here's one important line
Rook to f8 I want to show this line
because
there are a couple only moves that lead
white to Victory
and it runs like this after Rook F3 if
Bishop takes Bishop
we would give this check
another check win the bishop and what do
we do if the king tries to run
this is an only move Queen H5
only move that would win Queen H5 with
an ion
C5
and then another only move Rook H7
cutting off the king
Paving the way for Queen H5 a mate and
two threat right around the corner
there's no defense here
no minor piece move will stop Queen H5
Queen F7
and if well the queen can't go too far
she has a responsibility fending off
made on E7
any Rook lift F7 or F5 allows Rook h8
this is winning for team White
so in the game instead of Rook f8 it is
Bishop takes Bishop
we of course take with the pawn
not exchanging Queens
rookie 7 looking for some defense along
the seventh rank
Queen H6 there's no time to block in
this position
with Rook H7 because Rook f8 and mate
next move
so
King G8 and now G6 there is a third
attacker in this position it is not just
the queen in The Rook attacking this
Pawn plays a key role
it's almost like it's worth
three points maybe more so
and what are what are these guys doing
in the queen side
no good solution here for black
it's easy to go wrong as white
I've been drawing attention to some Rook
lift a rook lift at this point would
spoil the win for white
and the best that could come about would
be a draw if Rook F3 why is this the
case well The Rook could play to H7
check G7 white would actually have to be
a little bit careful here
not going back to H6
that would be winning for black because
of Queen takes G5
the queen would have to go to H5
now this would be poison
Rook takes Pawn is going to lead to a
mate in a few
Rook H3 nearby
and if Queen takes Pawn Black's gonna
have to give up the queen soon
this would be winning for white
my point here is that the best for both
sides would be a Perpetual if white is
playing Rook F3 right now
if white allows Rook H7 so what is the
pawn move doing it's stopping Rook to H7
it's also Paving the way for Rook F7
that could hit
in this game Knight D7 is played if Rook
G7
The Rook could already enter
Rook takes Pawn takes King takes and
this is going to be winning for white
King here check
wherever the King goes
The Rook is just going to give check the
queen will soon be lost and probably the
bishop and then black is
in a pin
okay
in the game Knight D7
Rook F3 only now
Knight f8 doubling on the f-file Knight
takes Pawn Rook G3
Rook G7 Rook takes Knight that's the
final move of the game black resigns
there's nothing to do here threatening
maintenance one
uh Rook takes Rook there's Queen takes
rook and once more we have some Rook
lift at this point we could go all the
way to the seventh mating two from here
some other try
this one maybe
you could play Rook F3 that's considered
best it's reading a mate in 10. I think
many players might go straight in for
Rook F6 knowing that you're going to be
winning the queen soon and winning the
queen is going to be a win so
how might this flow
you could do something like this
and start running with the H Pawn
yeah this is absolutely winning so
plenty of ways to do it at this point
these guys are just not around at all to
defend
and a beautiful attacking game uh it was
what I found interesting was the how
this F Pawn ended up turning
out to play a very key role in the
attack as the positions start to
simplify little by little no minor
pieces on board that pawn really did
uh seem to act like it was a minor piece
for wider worth at least a minor piece
for white in the attack
anyhow let's have a look at the tail the
tape on this one we could see
how clean a game it was for a dingler in
if we have a look at the
inaccuracies this is the main
main uh issue with Black's play going
with C5 rather than Knight to C6 with
the the idea to swing over to E7 and
then either F5 or G6
that was the inaccuracy and it's a
difficult task ahead at that point for
black to defend
uh accuracy for Lou shangley 86 and a 95
dingler in so
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye